fate and the fleet of France newly elected
president Wong Kar a of France watches French
flag being hoisted over ship keyboards in waters
off to home its 1913 and with whispers of war in
Europe growing gradually into more loudly spoken
words head to French government reviews his
nation's fleet soon to be locked in ocean warfare
against u-boats and merchant ships of the kaisers
armadas here's battleship of the gigantic the
Jean bark class 20 3,500 tons of fighting fortress
with miserable Darrin Nations Minister of Navy
President Wong Kar a gets satisfying look at
French answer to threat of u-boats submarines
of France and here's past French destroyer
fully prepared to guard Atlantic sea lanes and
interests of trivalent um captain the flagship
joins Monsieur blinker a and bull down as from
battleships to barges French fleet of 1913 proves
its readiness for anything future might bring and
what it brings his war in 1914 for long for years